Senator what do you think about
representative Marjorie Taylor Green's
call on social media for a national
divorce dividing the country up between
Republican and Democratic states you
know I think Abraham Lincoln dealt with
that kind of uh Insanity we're not going
to divide the country it's uh united we
stand divided we fall yeah listen I
didn't vote for Mitt Romney but he does
seem like a fundamentally decent and
honest guy who just tells you what he
thinks and he thinks a lot of Modern
Republicanism is completely insane now
I've told you the two main reasons why
this entire separate into two countries
won't work the first is the
unconstitutionality of unilateral
secession now baby maybe Marjorie Taylor
green is talking about a version where
like everybody agrees everybody's like
no yeah yeah like Oklahoma you should go
go do your own thing but the
Constitution of the United States which
is the supreme law of the land doesn't
provide a provision for secession